こんにちははじめしゃちょーです全員作っ
てしまいましたスライム上アスレチック
よくあるじゃないですか会場アスレチック
とかプールの上のアスレチックとか
甘いプールとか会場とか水の時代も終わり
ました新時代スライムの上のアスレチック
2日間かけて作りましたご覧くださいこの
フィールド縦横10mの超巨大プールに
スライムを2500リットルぶち込みまし
たプールがでかすぎて2500リットルの
スライド全然入ったのでたくさん障害物を
入れてスライムの量をちょっとかさ増しし
たらめっちゃいい感じにねご覧ください
スライムで
埋まりましたいろんなもの置いて
アスレチックが完成したのでもう世界に一
つしかないでしょうスライムに落ちたら
ゲームオーバーなアスレチック作ってみ
ました結構いろんな仕掛けとかあるので1
回ちょっと見ていきたいと思います
というわけでデモンストレーションです
どういうコースなのか紹介していき
ましょうここがスタート位置です用意
で行くとまずは滑り台があります
ここ
ヌルヌルになってます
今はなってないんですけどね本番は
ヌルヌルになっててスライム落ちると
ゲームオーバーなのでここら辺でピタッと
止まります
止まったら次この
[音楽]
綱渡りのようにここを渡り
渡った後にゲーミングチェアが回転して
ますこれになんとか
飛び乗って飛び乗って次のゲーミング
チェアに行きます
[音楽]
行けました
ここ渡れなくなってるのってこう来て次
このポークかわしながら下をくぐり
[音楽]
そり立つ壁
ここしっかりと
登っていきます
登った先にストーリーがありますそれに
乗ります乗りましたで
滑り降ります
気をつけましょうで次はジグザグ
スラロームです
でコックに乗って
ジグザグな机ですねこれをテックテック
滑りやすいのに気をつけながら渡り
ましょう次は平均台なんと
超強風が吹いてます
[音楽]
耐えながらバランスを取ってここは
次ここ何とか飛び乗ります
[音楽]
飛び乗ってポンポンポンといってちょっと
ヌルヌルするんですけどもこのドラム缶の
スライムロードなんとか
渡りぴょんぴょんぴょんと来てゴールに
なります
[音楽]
さあ前人未到の挑戦が始まりますまず
ファーストチャレンジャーははじめしゃ
社長その意気込みは怒りスライムっていう
のって結構あの僕となじみがあるのでこう
いうスライムプールみたいななんて言うん
でしょうこうアスレチックはマジで余裕
ですスペシャル
さあいよいよスタートしましたこの
スライムアスレチック男闘ヘルメットを
よく見るとうまくはまっていないでしょう
か
ついてまずは滑り台を突破そして
慎重に渡った後第2関門のくるくると回る
椅子です早めに移動しなければいけません
難しそうですね
これは邪魔してるぞ大丈夫なのか大丈夫な
のか
あくまでもこの2500リットルの
スライムにつかなければOKというルール
の中でこのアスレチックが行われています
なんとか2つ目の椅子に乗った後さあここ
でこの
椅子を突破していきましたギリギリの中
フワングワンと揺れるこのアスレチックの
中で立つ壁登ってまいりますそしてそれに
手をかけたまたここも滑っていこうという
構えのはじめ社長です
もうようやくしっかりとはまった状態の
まま
処理滑っていきましたここもクリアですね
ここからです残り1分となったところで
どこまで進めるのかゴールまで行けるのか
どうかうわ足元はかなりこの
ムラついているようにも見えますただまだ
スライムには足をつけていません
油断すると危ないですよこことか
あまりにもこいつやりましたわあっけなく
ちょっと空気悪くなりますね
それではリプレイをご覧いただきましょう
このくるくると回る椅子なんですがここ
ポイント初めて社長いかがでしょうそう
ですねもうこのギミック自体を止めて
しまうというこれ人力で回っているので
もう先に人を掴んで妨害してしまうと椅子
自然と止まってしまうんですねそうですね
ここうまく突破していきましたはいそして
この問題のシーンですここ
振り返るといかがだったでしょうかこれは
非常にないっすねーその失敗した悔しさと
いうより取れ高の悔しさみたいなものが彼
から私感じ取れましたそうですね何かこう
今年YouTubeを始めましたという
ようなそんな虚しさを感じましたね
ここですね
これは本当に登録者数1000万人超える
YouTuberの姿なんでしょうか
あくまで何か爪痕を残したいという強い
意志を感じられました
悔しいですね
一番嫌な感じで終わってしまいました
ポイントとしてはやっぱりこの
机の滑り方が
妙にいやらしい本当にできれば頭から行き
たかったですね
最低ですさあセカンドチャレンジャーです
第1区おっと白い胴体が白いからの顔が
黒い
コントラストだスライム
食べれるの
全部食べちゃうよ
さあはじめ社長が誇るこの白豚の挑戦と
言っていいかもしれません金人なのでね
結構その間取りとか裏庭も詳しいと思い
ますそうですね
くるくると回転しながら降りていってまだ
スライムにはついていませんここはセーフ
ですこれ体の重いので体がコントロール
できてるかどうかがポイントになりますね
ちょっと安定感もあるかもしれませんこの
第二関門と回りいっすさあ2つ目の椅子に
乗り移れるかどうかちょっとここで時間を
使っているからちょっともたついてますね
これスタッフちょっと優しめにゆっくり
回してるようにも見えるんですけれども
なかなかやはりその自分の体重と相談し
てるんでしょうねなるほどその言って
しまった時の重さで倒れてしまう可能性が
あるのでかなりここが心臓に行きたい
ところではありますちょっと目が回って
しまわないかというところが心配なところ
スター2つ目あっとまたいだ大丈夫か
大丈夫か大丈夫大丈夫落ちてしまったこれ
は早い色のスライム
さあリプレイご覧いただきましょうまず
最初のかもうここ少し体勢を崩してしまっ
たでしょうかやはりその体重が増えてきて
はいるのでかなり体のその身のこなしは
バランス悪くなっちゃってるのかなって
いう気がしますねそうですねそして問題の
シーンですこの1つ目の椅子からなかなか
2つ目進めないそして2つ目に進んだかと
思ったら
ここで体勢を崩すというやや足が短かった
のもまたポイントですね
あまりにも無念
目が回ってしまいました回転椅子にいる
時間が長すぎて目が回りましたね
さあ3人目のチャレンジャーです
1分余らせます
運動神経は割といい方なので僕いけると
思ってます実はそうですねかなり自信の
あるコメントも残していましたなんて言っ
てたかは全く分かりませんでした
危ない
ギリギリですね足が長い分その分こう
スライムに着きそうになったかという
シーンでしたまず最初おっとここは
太い方をもっと縁の部分これ外側もコース
アウトです
がただこれですね
離れてるんですね椅子からなるほど
[音楽]
安定してジャンプはできるんですが
ちょっと
届きましたねかなり
危ないギリギリですなんとかスライムに
つかないように
椅子に乗ることがまたできないようやく
ここスタッフの手も借りながらという
らしいんでしょうか1つ目の椅子に乗り
ましたこれ時間との戦いになりそうですね
そうですね制限時間2分いっぱい余らせ
ますというようなことを言っていた
選手なんですねここでようやく椅子突破2
つ目の椅子はすんなりとクリアすることが
できましたうんここでようやくそびたつ壁
登ってまいりますそしてソニーに手をかけ
てここで残り1分半分まで進めているん
でしょうかこれ結構ギリギリじゃないです
かね
乗れていないか
滑って降りて行こうというところなんです
がようやく滑っていけましたはいさあここ
からです問題の
難関が待っていますこの
板の上をねしっかりと
渡れるかどうかはじめしゃちょーはここ
までまあ
軽くも落ちてしまうというようなことが
ありましたしかしなかなかこの何でしょう
なんてことがないところでちょっと苦戦し
てるんでしょうか
ギリギリちょっとアホなのでカレーそう
ですね
分かっていないのかもしれませんさあ
ようやく時間をかけて
木の板の上に乗ることができました1つ目
の板さあまっすぐすることはできました2
つ目の移動で残りが10秒です
いかなければいけません最後のところ平均
台まで足をかけたところ落ちてしまった風
に流されましたかねこれなるほどはいさあ
リプレイご覧いただきましょう最初の
ところしっかりとこのねスタッフの
腕を掴むというシーンもありました性格の
悪さが出てますね
ギリギリでしたそしてこのシーンですここ
も時間をかけたのが良くなかったちょっと
またついてましたねそして最後は風に流さ
れるという
静岡のさんさんと降り注ぐ日差しのもと
スライムに飛び込んでいきました2位です
さあ4人目のチャレンジャーです
ここははじめしゃちょー一番ですの意地を
見せられるかと思います
バカなんですかね絶対にやってはいけない
滑り台の滑り方をしましたさあここで追加
情報が入ってまいりましたらこの男は最近
食べているご飯全てはじめしゃちょーのお
金で食べているとそうですねほぼ養って
いると言っても過言ではないと
ちょっとそのね期待に応えられるかどうか
そうですね
何が起きた何が起きたんだこれちょっと
リプレイ見ましょうかはいまず
最初とよくわからない滑り方
滑るのか頭から言ってるぞ海老反りです
海老反りをした後このね頭が
刺さってしまったんじゃないかと思う
ぐらいこの滑り台に刺さっていたんですが
この後ですここもなぜか取りに乗って進む
ところなんですがどこにゴロンと細い持っ
ていたのか全部頭から言ってますね彼全く
何が起こっていたのか常人には理解でき
ない身のこなしをしていきましたサーブ
です頭からスライムに突っ込むという結末
でしたそしてヘルメットもなくなってます
ね
机ですね
机のヌルヌルがもう
大丈夫か
と思ったさあ
泣きの1回はじめしゃちょーの再挑戦が
始まりますあまりにも先ほどの挑戦では
無念が過ぎましたちょっとリベンジしたい
という気持ちもあるんでしょうね
やはり1回コースを見ているので
挑戦したのでかなり頭に入ってると思うん
ですよコースがそうですね
滑り台のところを
そうですね回転する間もなく椅子を渡り
そして反り立つ壁もクリアそれもしっかり
サーブとは違いますねこの辺り違いを見せ
ていきます
ねこの時期の静岡の日差しは本当に強い
ものがありますそしてここはまだヌルヌル
している先ほど無念のシーンがありました
悲劇の部分超えていきました
そしてこの風ですここも非常に
危ないところではありますね
体そして
机に足をかけるしっかりと登って
危険な落ち方をしてしまいましたリプレイ
ですちょっと風の影響もあったんですかね
今そうですね最後は風に吹かれたかさあ
リプレイご覧いただいています
椅子のところ
序盤戦かなり順調に進んでいましたそして
先ほどあまりにも無念だったしもうなんと
かここもクリアしていくこの直後だったん
ですねいやーこの後風が吹くところ平均台
も渡って足をかけたこの机の上でしたここ
で体重
机に任せようとしたところ
このまま
ギリギリ
耐えられず
机ごとスライムにドボンと落ちていきまし
た
悔しそうな表情ちょっとなんなら美味しい
みたいな顔してますね
社長は特別な訓練を受けていますので皆
さん絶対に真似しないようにしてください
柔らかくてよかった
[音楽]